now are you getting baby gifts here's
what I found a lot of baby gifts before
my daughter was born and then my son
drop off I'm imagining there's you still
get them so many are you still had a lot
and the technology and baby gifts is
it's they all make noise now yeah like
when we were growing up there was one
toy that made noise right Speak & Spell
yes that was it that was it
everything else just shut up yeah but
now everything is like you know the cow
says Moo and like the book they have
books now that make noise that like talk
that real ourselves yeah I used to be
able to say go in the corner and read a
book but now you go in the corner it's
like the Sheep says baa it's just
non-stop noise I need these
I need these toys to shut up it's too
loud
it's what's the most annoying gift that
you have received for one of your kids
all right so my mom who I loved dearly
she she bought this thing and it's a toy
I brought it it's a monkey and I'm gonna
show you yeah they put this either in
the commercial break and I didn't know
what it was and they said you were gonna
stay with this look at this little son
of a [ __ ] so what does it it says no
does it says love you uh-huh got this
from my oldest for Valentine's they
don't say oh this thing sucks let's some
of this ready for this yeah go
it doesn't stop it goes and goes and
goes okay there's a lot of things that
first of all it's a remake of a remake
right yeah so remake of you can't touch
this which was a remake of super freak
yeah so already I don't like the song I
don't like the arrangement I don't like
anything it's a bad arrangement and also
the vocals are it's too high-pitched
you're way too high pitch way too high
pitched and and and it goes all night
and sometimes you'll think it's you know
everyone's asleep it you'll hear in the
middle of night you'll hear I don't know
I don't know it kid rolls over or
something I'll tell you why it's a demon
from Hell sent here to destroy my life
you know what I would like to do is I
would like to kill it right now no the
tool I want to kill the toy right now
because I can't do it at home because if
I do that that's messed up yeah that
would make you a bad dad
yeah yeah which I'm not what if I do it
here it's a bit right if you do it here
your your showbiz Hey
and my daughter she'll cry she'll cry
but I will explain to her
listen Conan is a very big influence in
my life like you mean a lot to me I want
to have a good appearance yeah I'll show
her monorail yeah
Simpsons monorail he wrote that so you
know what's at stake right but that
should do it
yeah nothing else yeah yeah let's kill
this son of a [ __ ] so wait you okay
yeah go for it what do you it's all
right it's your mom gave this to you my
mom was gonna be fine
have you told your mom you're gonna do
this she'll be fine she'll watch your
show later on we'll have a nice it
should be singing while you kill it
[Applause]
[Applause]
alright that's gone let me say this
thing I want to find the thing that
makes the noise that's the part I always
like oh you did it you pulled it right
out yeah that wasn't that this guy
wasn't bothering ya it was this I mean
this is the problem right maybe I can
bring this back home to my daughter
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you